as you know most of las vegas major
resorts are open again
slowly shows up and down the strip have
come back to life it's a bit of a taste
of normal and very abnormal times
but there is another hotel and
entertainment venue nearby that's just
trying to hang on
i visited death valley junction
california to see the most unique spot
of them all
it's a reminder of what could happen a
mural inside the amargosa opera house
and hotel
painted desolation sands twisting into
the air
a crystal ball into a world where this
outpost fades under the weight of
pandemic
it feels like a very magical place
general manager bobby fabian we are in
the middle of nowhere so
it is hard for people to kind of
remember that we're here and that we do
need help
marta beckett liked the isolation back
in 1967 the ballerina and her husband
stumbled onto death valley junction and
never left
this was her personal canvas her own
stage
when beckett died her ashes drifted into
the desert sky
we were there for the first performance
after her death in 2017.
we have what i call the beauty of decay
fred conboy keeps her spirit alive
it's getting harder to do we see that
the ruins of death valley junction
as not an option coronavirus forced it
all to close down back in march
the hotel reopened a few weeks ago but
only at half capacity
this is one of the few times anyone has
been in the opera house for months
beckett's painted audience never left
people do want to
you know see the stage being used and
might as legacy live on until then the
opera house and hotel have this gofundme
page
money raised helps keep the lights on
pay the few staff still here
and make sure marta's creation doesn't
drift away
something that needs constant work it's
like it needs to be nourished and loved
just like mata loved it
beckett found the poetry of living in
this remoteness
the next act is keeping her show alive
on the desert's most
desolate stage there's a conspiracy of
all those wonderful
things that come here that still offer
someone
a chance to feel
that this place will sustain even if it
were to fall into the
into dust unfortunately despite their
best efforts i spoke with
fred conboy via email yesterday he says
that the hotel
is going to close again in december
simply put
they can't get enough customers to make
ends meet however the hotel is still
raising money for expenses because they
still want to preserve the property so
they can open it later on
we have a link to the hotel's website
and the gofundme page
at eightnewsnow.com